WOULD WE PREFER THOMAS BRYANT 15
PLUS POINTS RATHER THAN TEN PLUS
POINTS IF WE CAN GET THE PARLAY
ON THE SCREEN IN ITS CURRENT
ITERATION, OR LUCA OVER EIGHT
AND A HALF ASSISTS RATHER THAN
EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS?
>> SO THERE'S A COMMENT IN HERE,
KELLY BEAN IS SAYING MAKE IT
EIGHT SINCE RYAN IS TALKING
ABOUT SPIDERS.
THAT A PRETTY -- I LIKE THAT
VIBE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> MAKE IT EIGHT LEGS?
>> NO, NO.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE EIGHT
ASSISTS VERSUS EIGHT AND A HALF.
>> OKAY.
>> IF YOU WANT TO MAKE IT --
KELLY, IF YOU WANT US TO MAKE IT
AN EIGHT LEGGED PARLAY, JUST SAY
THE WORD AND WE'LL DO IT.
>> DON'T MAKE THOSE PROMISES.
>> B THOMPSON SAID THOMAS 15
POINTS.
>> SO DID JAQUAN.
>> MAKE IT 15 PLUS.
>> B THOMPSON, B THOMPSON, CAN
WE MAKE THIS YOUR PLAY?
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SAY YOU CAME
IN HERE AND YOU SAY, NO, NO, NO.
JUST THE THOMAS BRYAN.
YOU COME IN HERE AND YOU DON'T
TAKE MY PICKS.
THOMAS BRYAN, I'M WILLING TO
GIVE TO YOU AS YOUR PICK.
>> I SEE A LOT OF SUPPORT AT 15
FOR BRYANT.
>> 15.
>> SO THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY.
WE HAVE LUCA DONSICH, EIGHT PLUS
ASSISTS, THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT
PLUS POINTS.
JAY SOME TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
I WOULD ALSO BE WILLING TO MOVE
THOMAS BRYANT TO THE 15 PLUS.
>> LET'S DO IT.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
480.
AGAIN.
>> CALL IT A DAY.
>> THAT'S BETTER.
>> CALL IT A PARLAY.
>> I WAS WRONG, INDEED.
KELLY BEAN IS CHECKING ME AND
SAYING SPIDER PARLAY.
GIVE ME EIGHT LEGS.
I'M KIDDING.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS ONE FEELS GOOD.
THIS ONE FEELS GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW, WHY DO YOU HAVE
THAT FACE?
>> IT'S JUST IT FEELS LIKE WHY
ARE WE DOING -- LIKE I DON'T
KNOW.
SIX LEGS IS A LOT.
LIKE WE JUST -- WE CAME ONTO THE
SHOW AND WE WERE STRUGGLING TO
HIT, SO LET'S HIT SOMETHING.
NOW I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE SIX LEGS
JUST TO HAVE SIX LEGS WHEN WE
COULD HAVE JUST BEEN RIDING
JASON TATUM 35 PLUS POINTS ALL
ALONG.
>> DIDN'T WE DO 30?
>> WE DO 25.
>> THAT'S COOL.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> IT'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, LOOK AT THIS.
TAKE OUT WILLIAMS' RYE BOUNDS
AND PUT JASON TATUM 30 POINTS
AND SEE WHERE WE'RE AT.
SEE IN HE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
>> IS THAT GOING TO DO MUCH FOR
US?
>> WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO?
>> GET US TO AT LEAST 500.
>> THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
>> WHY?
>> YOU'RE GETTING GREEDY.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO FORCE IT.
YOU'RE FORCING IT AND EVERY WEEK
YOU FORCE IT AND THEN --
>> THIS SOUNDS LIKE PENT UP
FRUSTRATION FROM YOU, GREG.
>> IT DOES.
I WANT TO WIN.
>> YOU'RE ACTING LIKE I DON'T
WANT TO WIN.
>> YOU'RE FORCING PLUS 500 WHEN
YOU DON'T NEED TO.
WE HAD TO LOCK THAT PLUS 300,
PLUS 330.
>> NO, I LIKE THIS.
>> SEE?
BECAUSE IT'S PLUS 500.
>> IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS WHY I LIKE IT, YES.
>> IS PRINCE IN THE CHAT SAYING
A WIN IS A WIN.
I GOT TO GO WITH THE PEOPLE AND
GREG TONIGHT, MAN.
WE'VE DONE YOUR PARLAY THE LAST
THREE WEEKS, MAN.
IF IT'S PLUS 480 FOR SIX LEGS,
IT DOESN'T MATTER, BECAUSE THE
MONEY IS GOING TO CASH AND WE'RE
GOING TO -- AND MY MAN DARIAN IS
GOING TO GET A CHANCE TO TAKE
HIS LADY TO DINNER.
YOU WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
HIM NOT TAKING HIS LADY TO
DINNER?
I DON'T WANT TO LIVE WITH THAT
ON MY CONSCIENCE.
>> NO, I DON'T.
I DON'T WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT.
I ALSO SAID I WOULD LIKE TO DO
THE SAME THING.
>> HEY, RYAN?
>> YEAH, WHAT'S UP?
>> I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO CONSULT YOU
OFF.
I WAS JUST GOING TO READ A
COMMENT FROM THE PEOPLE.
>> GO AHEAD.
I WAS JUST GOING TO RECAP THE
PARLAY.
ROCK, PAPER, SCISSORS?
>> BAN KID 019 SAYS THAT'S HOW
YOU LOSE BETTING, TO GET
SPECIFIC ODDS.
THE PEOPLE.
AND YOU'RE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> KING OF THE RATS ACTUALLY,
PLEASE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU GOT TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE.
>> I AM LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE.
>> SO MAKE IT PLUS 480 AGAIN SO
WE CAN GET OUT OF HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LIKE IF YOU'RE LISTENING TO
THE PEOPLE, TAKE LUCA DOWN THE
SIX --
>> NO, NO.
>> BY THE WAY, ALSO, SO THIS IS
A FIVE LEG PARLAY.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGS.
SO HERE IT IS.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGS IN THE SAME
GAME.
WE HAVE LUCA EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS,
THOMAS BRYANT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS, WILL HE DROP 30 PLUS
POINTS.
THOMAS BRYANT 15 PLUS POINTS.
AND JASON TATUM 30 PLUS POINTS.
THAT'S ALSO MY OTHER THING HERE.
>> HERE GOES RYAN.
>> I JUST LIKE THE FOUR LEGS IN
THE SAME GAME.
>> HERE YOU GO.
>> FOUR LEGS MATTER.
>> IT'S IN THE SAME GAME.
>> WHO CARES?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
WHO CARES?
[LAUGHTER]
>> OKAY.
CHAT.
THIS IS -- ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL SCROLL THROUGH AGAIN.
>> WAIT.
WHAT IF WE TAKE OUT WASN'T IT
SIX LEGS?
>> LUCA --
>> RIGHT.
WE TOOK OUT --
>> WE TOOK OUT ROBERT WILLIAMS.
>> WHAT?
>> WE HAD SIX REBOUNDS.
THAT'S A LOT.
>> THAT IS A LOT.
>> BUT HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
US.
IT WAS LIKE MINUS 3,000.
>> RYAN, I DON'T THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND, MAN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING, BRO.
WHAT?
AND ROBERT WILLIAMS IS MADE OF
GLASS.
I DON'T THINK YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND.
WE WOULD BE LUCKY IF HE FINISHED
THIS GAME.
>> HE JUST RESTED FOR A WHOLE
GAME.
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
>> OH, MY GOD.
GREG, I DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE
TO TELL THEM TO PUT RYAN'S
PARLAY ON HERE AGAIN.
>> OKAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> IS THAT WHAT -- COME ON, MAN.
THIS IS HAPPENING WEEK AFTER
WEEK, RYAN.
>> ON WOULD THIS MAKE YOU GUYS
FEEL BETTER IF WE DID IT THIS
WAY?
IF WE ADDED ROBERT WILLIAMS?
>> WE'RE GOING TO TAKE TATUM
BACK DOWN TO 25, LIKE WE SAID.
>> TELL 'EM, MB.
>> AND CAN WE DO THAT, PLEASE?
BECAUSE I'LL FEEL A LOT BETTER.
>> THANK YOU, RYAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THERE WE GO.
BOOM.
PLUS 480.
LET'S GO GET THIS CASH, MAN.
>> WHAT IS IT? WHAT'S THE BET?
WHAT'S THE BET?
>> LET'S DO THIS.
>> DO YOU HEAR THE DEPRESSION IN
HIS VOICE?
HERE COMES A THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> WE HAVE LUCA DONSCICH, EIGHT
PLUS ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
LEBRONS JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, LEGACY GAME,
APPARENTLY, 15 PLUSES POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, IS SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
JASON TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
THAT IS SIX LEGS.
>> YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
>> PLUS 480.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, THOUGH.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
>> DON'T LIE.
>> TAKE LUCA ASSIST TO SIX.
>> WHY?
>> NO.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
>> EIGHT AND A HALF?
THE ONLY REASON WHY WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT IS BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
THE FIRST COMMENT BEFORE THE
SHOW EVEN STARTED.
>> OH, THAT'S TRUE.
>> HE GIVES US EIGHT.
>> THAT'S B. THOMPSON.
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S B. THOMPSON'S LEG.
DARIAN SAYS I NEED SOME MILK.
I'VE HIT MY DAIRY LIMIT.
>> I WISH I WAS BY THE FRIDGE.
I WOULD HAVE GOT YOU SOME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M GOOD WITH THIS.
ASK THE CHAT.
CHAT, THUMBS UP?
THUMBS DOWN?
IF WE'RE GOOD WITH THE SIX LEG
PARLAY AT PLUS 480.
I LOVE IT.
>> DOUBLE O SAYS LEBRON IS NOT
DROPPING 30 TONIGHT IN ALL CAPS.
JUST JUMPED TO PLUS AN # 530.
WHAT MOVED?
THOMAS BRYANT, OF COURSE, AND
LEBRON.
ALL RIGHT.
AND THOMAS BRYANT AGAIN.
>> IS GUYS, I'LL TAKE THE LEBRON
LEG AS MY LEG AND I DON'T CARE,
BECAUSE HE IS LITERALLY JUST --
HE'S JUST WATCHING FOR THIS
RECORD THAT HE'S GOING TO BREAK.
I SWEAR IT.
AND HE KNOWS THAT IF HE HAS 35
TONIGHT, HE'S GOING TO GET ALL
OF HIS FOLLOWERS AND THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE BY 15.
IT'S PERFECT.
I'VE ALREADY WATCHED IT HAPPEN.
>> YOU'VE SEEN --
>> THE ONLY THING THAT, LIKE,
HAS ME SECOND-GUESSING OR
THINKING IN THIS PARLAY IS
LUCA'S ASSIST.
I FEEL LIKE PERSONALLY, HE'S
MORE DEPENDENT AS FAR AS IN A
REBOUNDER THAN THROWING ASSISTS,
BECAUSE, LIKE, HE SCORES A LOT.
WE KNOW HE'S GOING TO REBOUND.
>> YEAH.
BIG ON LOCKS AND SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
SORRY.
THE SNAKE SAID SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
>> OH, SNAKE VERSUS RAT.
WE NEED TO DIAL THAT UP.
>> YEAH.
>> L BAY ALSO SAYS LUCA
REBOUNDS.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK I'M
PUSHING ANY PROPAGANDA, BRYAN.
>> THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOU AND I.
I DON'T ACCUSE YOU OF PUSHING
PROPAGANDA.
I LISTEN.
I ABSORB.
I'M LIKE A SPONGE, GREG.
I TAKE EVERYTHING.
I TAKE THE HATE.
I TAKE THE SLANDER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE LOVE YOU, BRO.
WE LOVE YOU.
>> I WOULDN'T WANT TO DO THIS
SHOW WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
>> IS AWE, I LOVE YOU, TOO.
SIX PLUS.
>> SPONGE OF LOCKS, SOMEBODY
SAID A SPONGE OF LOCKS.
SO FUNNY.
SIX PLUS REBOUNDS IN.
>> NO.
>> MINUS 1050?
>> GUYS, WHAT ARE WE DOING?
THIS IS VEN LEG PARLAY.
>> WE'RE CLOSE TO KELLY'S EIGHT
LEG SPIDER PARLAY.
>> TAKE OFF THE ASSISTS.
TAKE OFF THE ASSISTS.
>> TAKE THE ASSISTS OFF.
>> WATCH, WATCH, WATCH.
>> WHY NOT?
I JUST WANT TO SEE --
>> IT'S PLUS 416.
>> NOT FOR SIX LEGS.
NOT FOR SIX LEGS.
I LIKE WHAT WE HAD BEFORE.
>> WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
480 AND 416? YH.
WAIT.
HOLD ON.
WHAT'S HIS -- I DON'T LIKE THAT.
WAIT, HIS ASSIST JUMPED TO NINE
AND A HALF?
THAT'S GOOD FOR US.
>> YEAH.
SO LET'S LEAVE IT AT EIGHT
BEFORE WE MOVED THAT SHIT -- I
JUST SWORE.
I'M ABOUT TO GET FIRED.
>> IS YOU CAN CURSE ON HERE.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN.
>> I'M JUST FIRED UP, MAN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN AND I THINK
THE EIGHT IS THE LOCK.
>> YEAH.
I THINK SO, TOO.
I LIKE WHAT WE HAVE.
DO WE WANT TO RECAP IT ONE MORE
TIME AND, AGAIN, FINAL CALL OR
THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN?
YEAH, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH.
LET'S GO.
>> THOMAS BRYANT, MAN, IS GOING
TO -- THE 15- PLUS IS GOING TO
--
>> NO, NO.
THIS LUCA EIGHT ASSISTS IS
REALLY GOING TO SIT WITH ME.
>> EIGHT ASSISTS?
SO WE DON'T FEEL GOOD.
>> WHAT IF YOU MOVED BRYANT DOWN
TO TEN NOW THAT IT'S PLUS 534?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS SCARY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS A BIG -- GOSH, GOSH.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YEAH.
WE FEEL -- IT SEEMS LIKE WE FEEL
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE ABOUT THIS.
>> NO.
I DON'T NECESSARILY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHY THE ODDS
MOVED SO MUCH.
I'M COOL WITH THE THOMAS BRYANT
--
>> 15.
ME, TOO.
>> THE LUCA STUFF MOVED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR US.
I'M COOL WITH LUCA.
AND ALSO, THAT WAS THE ONE, WE
OB THOMPSON ONE.
>> B THOMPSON, DO YOU LIKE THAT
LUCA PLAY OR DO YOU LIKE ANOTHER
ONE?
COMMENT IF YOU LIKE ANOTHER ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M DOWN TO KEEP IT, BUT IF
YOU LIKE ANYTHING ELSE, YOU JUST
LET US KNOW.
>> OH, HE JUST SAID WHEN LUCA
EIGHT ASSISTS HIT AND YOU ALL
DON'T TAKE T I'LL PERSONALLY HIT
YOU UP.
WE'VE GOT TO RIDEITH IT.
>> DARIAN 85, 15 POINTS FOR
THOMAS BRYANT ISCARY.
WE'VE GOT KYREE2 PLUS AND THREE
IN HIS HERE.
THE KYREE, WE LOOK AT KYREE AND
THE THOMAS FOR TEN POINTS IS NOT
GOOD.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
WHAT IF WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THOMAS BRYANT RIGHT
NOW?
>> DO WE JUST TAKE HIS
OVER/UNDER, WHICH I BELIEVE,
WHAT IS IT?
11 AND A HALF OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IN.
>> OKAY.
WAIT.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE NOT GOING TO LOVE
THIS.
WHAT IF WE TAKE -- WHAT IF WE
TAKE THE THOMAS BRYANT POINTS
OUT AND WE BUMP TATUM TO 30
PLUS?
>> DON'T HATE THAT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> NOPE, GREG, THIS IS IT.
>> THANK YOU, BULLY.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE JUST WATCH.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
NUMBER THAT MUCH, G.
>> YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT WINNING,
RYAN.
YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT.
>> DON'T YOU SAY THAT.
DON'T YOU PUT THAT ON ME.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT WINNING.
YOU DON'T.
YOU HAVEN'T SHOWED THAT.
YOU JUST CARE ABOUT GOING OVER
500, PLUS 500.
>> NO.
I'LL COOL WITH THIS.
IF WE WANT TO SETTLE ON PLUS 461
WITH THESE FIVE, THAT IS WHAT I
WILL DO.
I'M COOL WITH THIS.
LET'S TAKE OUT THOMAS -- HEY,
LET'S GET THOMAS BRYANT TEN
POINTS OUT OF THERE.
LET'S NOT DO THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
>> THOMAS BRYANT, WHAT'S HIS,
LIVE, OVER UNDER?
BECAUSE I'M SEEING A LOT OF
BRYANT 11 AND A HALF POINTS.
>> YEAH.
16 AND A HALF.
IT WAS 16 AND A HALF.
>> OH, WOW.
OKAY, YEAH.
NO.
WE'RE GOOD ON THAT.
>> WELL, WHAT DID YOU GUYS FOUND
OUT?
>> I DON'T DISLIKE JASON TATUM
TO GO OVER 30 POINTS, BUT IT
PROVES MY POINT.
IT'S RYAN PUSHING HIS PROPAGANDA
ON OUR PARLAY.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE THE POWER
FROM YOU AT LEAST ONE
WHATEVER.
>> HEY, YOU GUYS WANT TO SCROLL
FAN DUAL --
>> NEXT SHOW, LET ME SCROLL FAN
DUAL.
>> WE'RE IN TROUBLE.
>> BECAUSE MAN, I DON'T KNOW.
>> IRAN SAYS GREG, LET HIM KNOW
WE NEED WINNERS ONLY.
>> COME ON, MAN.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO WIN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN, RYAN.
I'M TRYING TO WIN.
>> RYAN, SORRY.
I'M NORMALLY THE MIDDLEMAN AND
I'M THE DEVIL'S ADVOCATE, BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GO BACK TO 25 POINTS AND
WE'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO RIDE
WITH THE ORIGINAL.
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY.
>> HEY, LOOK IT.
>> WHY?
>> TURN IT INTO RYAN'S PARLAY,
EYE ROLLS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, GOD.
>> JAQUAN SAYS RYAN IS PISSING
ME OFF.
JAQUAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
LIKE WHAT DO YOU WANT, THOUGH
IN.
>> WE TOLD YOU WHAT WE WANTED,
RYAN.
WE HAD IT.
>> YOU WANT THE THOMAS BRYANT
POINTS BACK?
>> YES.
THE PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY SAID IT.
>> SO WE'RE DOING A SIX LEG
PARLAY?
>> YEAH.
>> IS OH, GOD.
>> "LOVE HOW UPSET YOU GET.
IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
BAGEL AND LOX SAYS ROYCE O'NEAL,
25 BUCKS PLUS, PLEASE.
NOW WE'RE GETTING TO THE
TROLLING PART.
CHAT NOW.
>> DID THIS -- OKAY.
BIG MEACH, THIS GUY RYAN MAKES
YOU LOSE.
PLACE THE DAMN PARLAY NOW AND
CALL IT A DAY.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
I'VE TAKEN ENOUGH HEAT HERE.
I'LL CONCEDE.
15 PLUS?
>> YEAH, 15.
>> OKAY.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YEP, YEP, YEP, YEP.
>> THERE IT IS.
LET'S ROLL.
>> WHEN THIS HITS, I'M GOING TO
LOSE IT.
I'M GOING TO LOSE IT WHEN THIS
HITS.
SOMEBODY SAID, OVL ROSE SAYS IF
THIS TURNS INTO THE RYAN PARLAY,
I'M NOT TAILING.
>> BEING ON.
GUESS WHAT?
IT'S NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OB ROSE, RYAN LOST US MONEY
LAST WEEK.
>> AND DARIAN 85 SAYS GUESS ME
AND MY LADY EATING AT AT AT AT
WENDY'S FOR DINNER.
>> NO, BRO, WE'LL GET YOU RIGHT.
RYAN DIDN'T HAVE MUCH TO SAY ON
THIS ONE.
>> AND THAT'S THE DETERMINING
FACTOR FOR YOU?
>> I MEAN, THE LAST THREE WEEKS,
YOU KNOW.
>> WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS
THEY HAVE MORE FAITH IN THOMAS
BRYANT THAN THEY DO IN PRODUCER
RYAN.
IT'S TOUGH.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE
DISRESPECTED ON THE SHOW BEFORE,
I WILL SAY THAT.
>> BUT WAIT, WAIT.
>> IT'S ALL LOVE.
>> CAN YOU READ THE PARLAY ONE
MORE TIME AND THEN JUST KNOW
THAT WHEN THIS HITS, THE CHAT IS
GOING TO BE ON FIRE NEXT WEEK.
I JUST CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO THIS.
IT'S THOMAS BRYANT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
LEBRON JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
LUCA DONSCHICH, EIGHT PLUS
ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, LEGACY GAME, 15
PLUS POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS.
AND JASON TATUM, 25 PLUS POINTS.
PLUS 546.
SIX LEGS THIS TIME, NOT FIVE.
SIX.
>> I SEE CHECK MARKS BY B
THOMPSON.
HE'S IN FAVOR.
AND REMEMBER, YOU'RE PUTTING
THIS IN ON FAN DUAL.
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR MONEY BACK
IF IT LOSES, BUT IT WILL NOT,
BECAUSE RYAN HAD NO SAY IN IT
THE END OF THE PARLAY.
SO WE'RE ALL GOING TO EAT.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAVE NO WORDS.
>> I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS ONE.
RYAN?
>> WHAT, MAN?
>> YOU ALREADY READ THE PARLAY.
READ IT ONE MORE TIME FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T GET IT.
>> JUST FOR YOUR ENTERTAINMENT,
GREG.
>> THEY'RE JUST TROLLING.
HE COULDN'T READ THE PARLAY,
BECAUSE HE HAD NO SAY IN IT.
>> I'LL DO IT ONE MORE TIME JUST
FOR YOU, GREG.
WHY NOT?
LUCA, EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
THOMAS BRYANT, EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
THOMAS BRYANT, 15 PLUS POINTS.
JASON TATUM, 25 PLUSES POINTS.
LEBRON JAMES, 30 PLUS POINTS.
ROBERT WILLIAMS, SIX PLUS
REBOUNDS, PLUS 546.
THE CHAT'S PARLAY.
THE CHAT.
IT'S ALL OVER.
NINE CHAT WAS ALL OVER THIS ONE
TODAY.
>> RYAN, YOU'RE GOING TO SLEEP
SO MUCH BETTER TONIGHT KNOWING
THAT YOU HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS EITHER WAY.
SO I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A WIN/WIN
FOR YOU.
>> IT IS.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE A LOT OF AMMO NOW.
THERE'S A LOT OF BLAME THAT I
CAN PASS.
I WOULD NEVER, BECAUSE GREG, YOU
KNOW THIS.
I'M NOT AN I TOLD YOU SO GUY.
>> IS YOU'RE A BIG ONE, BIG I
TOLD YOU SO GUY.
WHAT'S YOUR RECORD ON THE SHOW?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN IT'S A
RECORD?
IT'S A PARLAY.
THERE WAS NO RECORD.
>> NO, NO, NO.
YOU DIDN'T GET THE JOKE.
IT'S OKAY.
WE'LL MOVE ON.
IF YOU GUYS WANT TO TAILOR A
FIVE LEG PARLAY, HEAD OVER TO
FAN DUAL AND TO WANT INTO THE
TNT THURSDAY'S NO SWEAT PARLAY
FOR A FREE BET IF IT LOSES.
WE'RE NOT GREAT AT ANY BETS
TODAY.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GET UP OUT OF
HERE.
RYAN, THEY TOLD ME TO HAVE YOU
READ THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME,
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT TO
YOU.
NOT GOING TO DO THAT TO YOU.
>> THE PEOPLE IN THE CONTROL
ROOM ARE CLOWNING ME JUST AS
MUCH AS YOU GUYS, BY THE WAY, ON
A DAILY BASIS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
>> THEY TOLD ME TO HAVE YOU READ
THE PARLAY, BUT YOU GUYS SEE THE
PARLAY RIGHT THERE.
RYAN DID NOT HAVE MUCH SAY SO IN
THIS PARLAY, SO WE ARE IN GOOD
HANDS, PEOPLE.
WE ARE IN GOOD HANDS.
MB, LET'S GET ON UP OUT OF HERE,
RYAN AND MB.
MY NAME IS GREG IVY.
NEXT TO ME IS MB.
I CALL HIM MB.
YOU GUYS MIGHT KNOW HIM AS
MICHAEL BOLEN.
I HAVE TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
ELSE THE MAN OF THE HOUR.
AND NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN WE
ALL LOVE.
RYAN, WE LOVE YOU, BRO.
PRODUCER RYAN, A/K/A, KING OF
THE RATS.
>> KING OF THE RATS.
>> A/K/A A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> HEY, WE'RE UP OUT OF HERE,
Y'ALL.
PEACE.